hi i'm bill kuzmal this is joint work
with michael bender and martin farage
colton
and this talk is based on the paper
what does dynamic optimality mean in
external memory
so i'm going to start this talk off with
just kind of a brief overview of
standard dynamic optimality what does
dynamic optimality mean in general
and then i'm going to talk about why
it's actually a really interesting
question how we should define dynamic
optimality when we're in external memory
so in order to talk about dynamic
optimality obviously we first have to
talk about balanced binary search trees
and
balanced binary research trees kind of
date back to the early 1960s the first
one was the avl tree
and then there were a whole bunch of
subsequent trees that people came up
with red black trees weight balance
trees later on things like trips
and what these all shared in common is
that they were rotation-based binary
search trees
so these are all different data
structures but they're all members of
the same class of data structures
and they all use rotations in order to
guarantee that the tree is never more
than logarithmic depth
so that's a pretty nice result
but one thing that people very quickly
noticed is that there are some special
cases at least where you can actually
hope to do better than logarithmic time
per operation
so for example one classic example of
this is if you consider a round robin
workload so somebody is just accessing
the numbers one two three through n over
and over again in the tree
then you can actually structure your
tree in a way so that
as these accesses occur each of them
actually takes an average of just
constant time
so one way to do that is to start your
tree as just being this very lopsided
chain with one at the top
and then after one is accessed you
rotate your tree so that two is at the
top and the next you rotate your tree so
that three's at the top and so on
so that each of these accesses only
takes constant time
and then at the end you just spend order
end time rebuilding your tree back to
its initial state so that the average
time per operation was just a constant
so this is a simple example where if
your tree adapts to the sequence of
operations that are occurring you can
actually do a lot better than the naive
logarithmic time that you might hope for
so in the mid-1980s this got slater
intelligent thinking well maybe there's
some search tree that's just kind of the
best possible binary search tree
and so they formalized this concept with
the notion of dynamic optimality so they
said a dynamic binary search tree t
would be dynamically optimal
against the class of all rotation based
binary search trees
if t
is constant competitive
against every other dynamic binary
search tree on every input
so what does that mean well this means
that your search tree t
has to be on every single input
just as good as a search tree that was
highly tailored to that specific input
so for example we saw on the previous
slide that it's possible
to construct a search tree that takes
constant time per operation
if your input is a round robin sequence
and r3t better also take constant time
for operation
but it has to do not just on that input
but on any input it has to be as good as
the best tree for that input
and one nuance that i think is worth
highlighting is that dynamic optimality
is defined against a class of data
structures
so in this case the class of data
structures is rotation-based binary
search trees
and that just means that we're trying to
be constant competitive against every
rotation-based binary search tree
so that's the notion of dynamic
optimality
and it's not obvious whether dynamic
optimality should be possible in fact we
still don't know whether it's possible
but slater and tarzan gave a candidate
tree that seems like a really good
candidate so they came up with the splay
tree
and indeed one of the most famous open
conjectures in the field of data
structures is can you prove that display
tree is dynamically optimal
so that's still an open question it is
known that the splay tree does really
well on lots of natural input sequences
and there's been a whole bunch of work
on dynamic optimality so i don't have
time to summarize it all here but
an example of another result you should
know about is the tango tree which came
much later in 2004
and which has the interesting property
that although it's not fully dynamically
optimal it is actually provably within a
log log factor of dynamically optimal
so that's classic dynamic optimality in
internal memory binary search trees
and what i want to pivot to next is
asking the question okay
what would dynamic optimality mean if
instead of talking about internal memory
we talked about external memory
and what we're going to see is that this
seemingly innocent question actually has
a lot of bite to it there's a lot of
interesting stuff going on here
so to start off with let's just review
the external memory model
what this model is trying to capture is
a setting in which your data doesn't fit
in internal memory instead you have to
store the vast majority of your data on
some larger external memory such as for
example a disk drive or maybe in the
cloud
and so the way this works is you have
some internal memory of some size m
for this talk we're basically just going
to think of m as being negligibly small
and then you have some large external
memory of unbounded size
where almost all of your data is stored
at any given moment
and you can access this external memory
by moving blocks of size b
so this is the main parameter you should
care about b
to and from external memory
so that means you can take any b
consecutive elements in internal memory
and write them to external memory or you
can take any b consecutive elements in
external memory and read them into
internal memory
and the way the external memory model
works is that that
is the thing that actually costs
something
so the running time of your algorithm is
measured in terms of the number of block
transfers to and from external memory
that the algorithm makes
that's the external memory model and
one thing that people have known for a
long time is that the external memory
model really changes how you should
design your data structures
so a classic example of this is the b
tree
which is kind of the classical analog to
a binary search tree except for external
memory
and the thing that's special about a b
tree is that each node has a large fan
out so instead of fan out two you have
fan out order b and that's because
you want to make your node be the size
of a data block you want a node to be
something that you can read or write to
external memory in constant time
and the way that you maintain this
invariant that each node has fan out
theta b
is that you sometimes merge and split
siblings so whenever a node's fan out
becomes too large you split it and
whenever
nodes have fan outs that are too small
you merge them with siblings
and because you have this larger fan out
this fan out of order b instead of two
b trees are faster than their classical
counterparts
at least in the worst case
so b trees have the property that every
operation takes time
order log base b of n
instead of just log n
so of course it's tempting to just start
talking about dynamic optimality except
in terms of b trees
but one thing you'll notice right off
the bat is that b trees actually aren't
rotation based search trees at all
so in particular b trees do have the
ability to move elements up and down the
tree so that maybe some elements are
cheaper to access than others
but instead of the elements moving due
to rotations elements are moving
due to nodes splitting and merging
so for example if you have a tree like
this and you have
a key x
here
well you could split this node at x
so now x appears in the next layer above
as a pivot
so that's how you could move a key
up
in the tree
and so that means the b trees are really
a specific data structure in a larger
class of data structures that you can
think of as being
merge split trees so trees that are
modified in this way
so this means we can talk about dynamic
optimality for b trees
and in fact in 2008 those at all showed
that there actually is a data structure
that is dynamically optimal against all
merge split trees
so that was a really nice result
but it also comes with kind of an
interesting catch
which is that it turns out that
even though there's a data structure
that's dynamically optimal against merge
split trees
there's actually certain natural
sequences of operations on which this
data structure still doesn't do all that
well
and that's just because actually no
merge split tree does well on that
sequence of operations
so a simple example of this is actually
the round robin workload that we saw
earlier in this talk already
and it turns out for that workload
merge split trees necessarily have to
take log base b of n time per operation
even though rotation based binary search
trees can do it in constant time for
operation
so this is kind of interesting because
yes we managed to define dynamic
optimality in external memory
but there's a feeling that maybe this
isn't the right definition of dynamic
optimality because somehow we ended up
with the data structure that was
dynamically optimal but still not that
good
and so the question is maybe merge split
trees aren't the right class of data
structures to consider when we're
talking about dynamic optimality
so much more recently in 2019 this led
demand at all to
consider a different class of data
structures
so they showed that there's a way you
can define kind of something analogous
to a rotation except for b trees
and this allowed for them to define a
class of data structures which we'll
call rotation based b trees
and then they were able to construct a
data structure that's within a log log n
factor of being dynamically optimal
against all rotation-based b trees
this is a really nice result because now
it puts internal memory and external
memory in the same arena as each other
now we're talking about rotation based
search trees in both settings
okay so is this the end of the story
and what i want to spend the rest of the
talk talking about is why actually
even this isn't the end of the story
so even rotation based b trees
aren't necessarily the right tree to be
looking at when you're talking about
dynamic optimality
and the reason for that is because b
trees themselves actually aren't always
the right way to do a search tree in
external memory
and that's because of an interesting
phenomenon that occurs in external
memory but that doesn't occur in
internal memory
in particular it turns out that in
external memory
there's an interesting asymmetry between
query operations so these are operations
that are looking something up within
your tree
and insert deletion or update operations
so these are the operations that are
modifying your search tree
so b trees have optimal query time
log base b of n
but it turns out it's actually possible
to make insertions deletions and updates
much faster than that
so let me show you why that is and just
to keep things simple i'm going to focus
on this talk on update operations so
these are operations that go and find
some key in your data structure and
modify the value that's being stored
with that key
and the way that you can make updates
faster than queries is to use a
technique known as buffer propagation
due to brothel and phagerberg in 2003
and the way this works is that you have
your you make it so your tree actually
has some fan out f that's actually
smaller than b
so now your nodes each have fan out f
instead of b
and each edge coming out of a node
has a buffer associated with it
a buffer that can store up to b over f
items
and the reason we choose b over f is
because well there's f buffers so this
means that within each node we're total
we're using a total of b space for our
buffers
and the point of these buffers
is that the job of a buffer is to
collect update operations that are
destined for the subtree
rooted at that buffer
so you collect update operations in your
buffer
so this is an example we just got
another update operation
and then whenever your buffer
fills up
when it's about to overflow that's when
you finally propagate those updates down
the tree
and this means that updates always
travel in batches so updates travel in
batches of size b over f
all together
and these updates now get placed into
the buffers in the node below
that's the idea behind buffer
propagation
and the result is that your queries now
actually take time
log base f of n because f is your fan
out so this could actually be larger
than what we had with b trees
but your updates get a huge boost
so
whenever we do work on updates we manage
to do work on
b over f updates at once and this has
the effect of decreasing the amortized
time per update by a factor of b over f
so you get a huge reduction
in time per update
so
one
kind of neat example of this to think
about is what happens if for example f
is square root b
so here we actually get the same
asymptotic time for queries that we had
with b trees
but updates actually take amortized time
a square root b factor than they did in
b trees
so this buffered propagation
technique what it means is that when
we're talking about external memory
search trees there are really two
different parameter regimes that we need
to consider
we need to consider on one hand
workloads that are dominated by queries
and for these workloads b trees are the
right thing to use which means that
the dynamic optimality results that
we've seen for rotation-based b trees
and for merge split-based b trees are
kind of the natural candidates these are
the results that we should be interested
in
but then the flip side is we also need
to consider update heavy workloads
so these are workloads where a large
amount of the cost that we're incurring
is actually from update operations
or you could also have insertion and
deletion operations
and here you want to use not standard b
trees but buffer propagated trees
which leads to the question
of what should dynamic optimality mean
in this update heavy setting
and that's the question that we tackle
in this paper
so the basic idea is that actually
a buffer propagated tree
has lots of opportunity to adapt to the
specific workload of operations that's
being performed
so where's the flexibility in this data
structure
well first of all different nodes can
have different fan outs so if you make
the fan out of a node larger what you're
doing is you're making it so that
queries that go through that node are
going to be faster because you're
decreasing the depth of the tree for
those queries
but
updates that go through that node are
going to be slower because
at that node they get batched into
smaller batches than they would have if
you had a smaller fan out
and so you can dynamically adapt how
friendly any given node is to updates
versus how friendly it is to queries
you can also it turns out carefully pick
the pivots in your tree in order to try
to split your workload in natural ways
so for example one thing you might try
to do is to pick a pivot
so that all of your updates go to one
subtree but all your queries go to a
different subtree
and that means that you could then
optimize those two subtrees differently
so that one is optimized for queries but
one is optimized for updates
and then finally you could change all of
this dynamically over time
so you could adapt to the way that your
workload changes over time
so what this means is that
buffer propagated trees
they're not b trees they're not rotation
rotation-based trees
but they are in a class of data
structures that has this ability to
adapt to the properties and especially
the locality properties of a workload
and what this class of data structures
is able to adapt to is the interplay
between update operations and queries
and so in workloads that are update
heavy
this is the class of data structures
that we should think about dynamic
optimality for
and so finally
we have an answer to our original
question how should we think about
dynamic optimality in external memory
well the answer of course is that it
depends on the setting
and in the update heavy setting the
question that we should be interested in
is does there exist a data structure
that is dynamically optimal
against all buffer propagated trees
and of course one of the things we do in
the paper is we formally define this
class of data structures so that this is
a question that's now well-defined
okay so
what i'm going to do in the last few
minutes of the talk
is i'm going to summarize the results
that we actually prove in the paper
addressing this question
so we do in the paper is we introduce a
new data structure that we call a jello
tree
and the first theorem that we prove i'm
just going to state it informally here
is that the jello tree
isn't dynamically optimal but it is
statically optimal
so what does that mean
that means that if you have a sequence
of operations that consists just of
query operations and update operations
the jello tree is dynamically optimal
against the class of static buffer
propagated trees
so it's constant competitive with buffer
propagated trees whose shape is fixed
these are trees that don't get to change
their structure over time
that's static optimality
so even this it turns out is a
non-trivial result
but then the next thing we consider is
we say okay well
maybe we can show some sort of continuum
between static optimality and dynamic
optimality
so what we aren't able to do is to argue
that
the gelatry is actually fully
dynamically optimal
in fact it probably isn't and it's a
really interesting open question whether
there even is
a dynamically optimal data structure in
this setting
but we can show that gel trees sit on
this interesting kind of horizon between
static and dynamic optimality
and in order to formalize that we define
the notion of a speed limited buffer
propagated tree
so we call a buffer propagated tree
k speed limited your k is a parameter
if the tree spends only a 1 over k
fraction
of its cost
on modifying the structure of the tree
modifying the shape of the tree
so a k limited
tree
isn't quite static it actually can
change its structure quite a lot over
time
but it's also not quite fully dynamic
because we're saying that it can only
use a small fraction a 1 over k fraction
of
its work of its cost
of its moving things to and from disk
it can only use a one over k fraction of
its cost to change the structure of the
tree
so the theorem that we prove is that the
jello tree is dynamically optimal
against the class of
b to the epsilon speed limited buffer
propagated trees
so here epsilon is a small positive
constant of our choice
and we're saying that if you consider
the class of buffer propagated trees but
you restrict them to be speed limited
then the jello tree actually is
dynamically optimal
so that's the main technical result in
the paper
and it turns out the gelatry ends up
being
a pretty
intricate structure both to define and
also to analyze and so one
open question is also just can we
replicate these results with a simpler
data structure is that possible
okay so the last thing i want to talk
about in this talk is i want to talk
about this notion of speed limitation a
little bit more
because i think it's an interesting way
to look at dynamic optimality
so this idea of speed limitation is
saying okay well
we want to argue that a data structure
maybe isn't fully dynamically optimal
but it's somewhere between statically
and dynamically optimal
and so there's two ways you can think of
it one is you can think of it as a form
of resource augmentation
so the way to think about that is we're
performing a competitive analysis
against an adversary which i'll call opt
and whenever you're performing a
competitive analysis you can
talk about this idea of augmenting a
resource so that you get more of it than
opt gets
so here what we're saying is you have
more ability to modify the tree than opt
does
so we modify
the task of modifying the tree costs k
times as much for opt
as it does for you
that's how you can think about speed
limitation as a form of resource
augmentation
another way to think about speed
limitation is as a restriction on the
inputs
on the sequence of operations being
performed
so in particular suppose we want to
consider inputs
who have the property that they're
that the optimal tree for that input
changes slowly over time
so this is essentially an input
whose where the properties of the input
are evolving slowly over time
well those would be precisely the inputs
for which a speed limited tree is
optimal
so one way to think about speed
limitation
is that you're proving
full dynamic optimality against the
subclass of inputs for whom the optimal
tree for that input evolves slowly over
time
so that's a little bit about speed
limitation
and now
having had a chance to present the main
results and also describe speed
limitation in a little bit more detail
i want to conclude the talk with two
open questions
so the first question
is just
how much further can you push this
concept of dynamic optimality against
buffered propagation trees
and in particular is there some data
structure is there some data structure
that even conjecturally is fully
dynamically optimal against all buffered
propagation trees
something analogous to the splay tree
that would be a really cool result
and then the second
question is
what would happen if we applied this
notion of speed limitation to binary
search trees in internal memory
so this would also give a continuum
between
static optimality and dynamic optimality
in internal memory
and what can we say about
dynamic optimality in that setting
so those are two questions that i'd be
really interested to see progress on
and that concludes the talk thank you
very much